the V Ches taught us that good is the
new bad and no one is better at being
good than Carlos this shy dog-loving
Brainiac is one of our favorite
characters but have you ever wondered
what will happen to Carlos after
descendants three stay tuned to find out
all about Carlos is happily ever after
descendants three Carlos has grown a lot
since the beginning of the first
descendants film he was too shy to speak
up for anything when we first met him
his mom karela Deville used him as a
servant seriously she was so full of
herself and she valued her fur coats
more than her own son so it's pretty
understandable that Carlos lacked a lot
of confidence his mom had also convinced
him that dogs were evil but it are done
crap he befriended dude the dog he
realized that dogs are the best and the
two are basically inseparable in
descendants two he joins the lacrosse
team
he also finally gets the courage to ask
Jane to the coronation ball these two
are perfect for each other
they both struggle with self-confidence
but are very fond of one another we
didn't see a lot of Carlos in the d3
trailer but we do know he is going to be
facing some serious challenges in the
new movie Carlos may be the son of a
villain but he was never really wicked
he's got such a pure hearts we think
Carlos will be the one to keep the rest
of the BK's from turning evil again he's
just such a good guy
scholarship Carlos can sometimes be a
little naive but he's not dumb in fact
he is really really smart he is really
into video games and computers in the
first movie it's his tech skills that
help the vks gain access to the fairy
godmothers wand
kids who are good at tech often score
some pretty epic scholarships and Carlos
is definitely going to want to go to
college Carlos will graduate from
auradon prep as one of the best students
Carlos will also score an amazing
scholarship to the top computer programs
in auradon he'll study hard and graduate
college with an amazing GPA but what
about his friends well Jay is amazing at
sports so we bet he'll become an athlete
when he goes to a university these two
will totally room together in college
they are besties after all Carlos could
have his pick of majors there are a lot
of
technology theme degrees he could pick
computer engineering software design or
computer science he could focus on video
games or apps
he's pretty creative so we back he'll go
into something like software development
carlos has unlimited potential he'll be
an amazing University students dating
jane carlos and jane are basically the
cutest couple ever they are both so shy
and a little awkward but they really
like each other they will definitely try
to keep dating after our time prep but
will they last most high school
relationships don't continue into
college jane will definitely go to a
university after they graduate but this
will be the first time that she is free
from her mom's overprotective
personality jane is going to want to
live it up here's what we think will
happen with Carlos and Jane Jane will
break up with Carlos for a while she'll
think she's too young to commit he'll be
heartbroken he really loves her and
doesn't want anyone else but these two
are just meant to be they'll keep
finding ways to come back to each other
by the end of college they will totally
be together again
Jane will realize like Carlos is the
perfect guy he's sweet and smart he's
caring and thinks she is amazing Jane
deserves Carlos and he deserves her
they'll stop fighting it and just be
together by this time fairy godmother
will really approve of Carlos she'll
accept him as a member of the family
dude the dog okay we know that Jay mal
and Evie are Carlos's best friends but
what about his other besties you know
the one that is a little bit furrier
than the others that's right we're
talking about dude the dog Carlos adores
dude and dude loves Carlos right back
dude was technically the school dog but
by the end of the first movie there's no
doubt about it he really belongs to
Carlos dude is the first person or
creature to make Carlos realize how
awful his mom is he realized that dogs
are not evil and dude helps him find his
confidence
we can't just expect Carlos to leave
dude behind right no way we think fairy
godmother will agree to officially give
dude to Carlos
she knows dude we'll be way happier
living with his favorite human and
because our Adan is a perfect magical
world dude gets to go to college with
Carlos he
help Carlos make even more friends at
college he'll be there to comfort him
when Carlos is sad about Jane Carlos
will make sure that do get spoiled
bright basically their relationship
won't change at all and that's the way
it should be dog walker
Carlos grew up poor on the Isle of the
Lost all the V Ches did he got a taste
of the good life at our time prep and he
isn't afraid of hard work sure Carlos
gets a scholarship to pay for school but
he needs money for other stuff like food
fun and taking care of dude he also
needs a job that works with his schedule
as a student and since he loves dogs he
picks the perfect college job he becomes
a dog walker
Carlos is amazing with dogs his clients
will love him and this is a pretty great
way to earn some good money people will
pay a lot for their pups to receive
plenty of exercise Carlos can also dog
sit for even more money he and dude can
go spend the weekend at someone's house
to watch their dogs yeah we'll give him
a nice break from his roommate Jay even
best friends need a little time apart
we just can't imagine Carlos having
another job in college he just doesn't
seem like the type of person to work as
a cashier and he got so tired of taking
orders from his mom he would hate being
a waiter yep we think walking dogs is
the perfect job for Carlos while he's in
school do you do things like walk dogs
for extra money tell us in the comments
tech genius unfortunately college
doesn't last forever
at some point Carlos like everyone else
is going to graduate and get a job so
what will Carlos do after graduation
he's going to make a lot of money
computer jobs usually pay pretty well
Carlos will graduate with good grades
and can get any job he wants and let's
not forget that he's a tech genius
Carlos is definitely going to be an
entrepreneur he's going to have a tech
startup that is super successful so what
will his business be let's look at his
passions he loves helping his friends
and since we know Evie is going to be a
successful fashion designer he could
design some sort of technology for her
he also has such a good heart he might
want to start some sort of tech company
for the kids on the Isle of the last but
there is one thing that Carlos is really
passionate about no not Jane dogs carlos
loves dogs carlos is definitely going to
design an app that helps dogs and dog
owners we're thinking about a
dog training app there will also be a
part of the app on how to get over your
fear of dogs Carlos loves dogs and
thinks everyone should he'll be super
successful they'll get rich and sell his
company for a lot of money what will he
do with all his money keep watching to
find out so the proposal sure Carlos is
going to have a really successful career
but we can't forget about Jane Carlos
and Jane are finally together they both
have successful careers and are just
enjoying life but they are super in love
carlos decides that has been long enough
he is ready to get married her whole
life has been spent in someone else's
shadow and it seems like she is always
planning an event for someone else she's
not royalty but she loves to get dressed
up and feel pretty so Carlos plans the
most romantic proposal ever he gets all
their friends together to plan a
birthday ball for Jane he's rich now so
this is not just a tiny party he goes
all out for once she'll get to be the
center of attention all he tells her is
that she needs to dress up in a fancy
new dress Evy designs a custom ball gown
for Jane Carlos sentence her to the spa
for the day then that night he picks her
up in a limo and takes her to her
birthday ball she's so surprised and she
feels so loved but then it gets better
halfway through the party Carlos stops
the live bands that he hired he takes
the mic and makes a speech about how
much he loves Jane then he gets down on
one knee and asks her to marry him she
says yes of course
Carlos is definitely fiance goals Mommy
Dearest if anyone deserves a totally
happy life its Carlos he grew up feeling
totally unloved he was used and abused
by korilla now we don't think there's a
lot of hope for mal or Evie's moms they
are really evil but Carlos is going to
finally confront his mom he's gained
lots of confidence so before he gets
married he tells her exactly how he
feels
karelas starts to feel some remorse and
she misses him though she won't admit it
so Carlos pays for them to go to Family
Therapy there they get to talk about all
of their issues it's not going to be
easy but Carlos is patient and karela
wants to be loved it takes a long time
but eventually karela apologizes they
never be super close but they have come
to an understanding
Carlos also helps other villains in the
island to be better parents he starts a
campaign to help villains show love to
their kids he doesn't want any more kids
to feel like he did and he vows that he
won't ever treat his future kids like he
was treated married life Jane and Carlos
have an amazing wedding between Jane and
fairy godmother every detail is planned
perfectly
Jane is a beautiful bride Evy designs
her wedding dress of course J is Carlos
his best man and dude is he cutest ring
their ever Jane and Carlos live in a
nice house on a lot of land in auradon
they both have their careers that they
can make lots of time for each other
they share all the housework and cooking
they have weekly date nights so even
when life gets busy they take time for
each other they love hosting all their
friends on the weekends dude has a huge
backyard
eventually Carlos rescues another dog
and then another one his business is
doing so well that he ends up selling it
now he has a lot of free time he and
Jane decide that this is a good time to
have a family he can be a stay-at-home
dad while she keeps her career and dude
is excited to have a new tiny human they
gather their closest friends and family
to tell them that Jane is expecting
fairy godmother is so excited to be a
fairy grandmother happily ever after
Jane and Carlos make the cutest kids
their first baby is a boy they have two
more kids a girl and another boy Carlos
is a great dad but in the meantime he
keeps rescuing more dogs he builds a
whole building for the canines Jane is a
little annoyed but she knows Carlos is
just really passionate about his furry
friends she suggests that he started dog
rescue it's brilliant
Carlos spends his days taking care of
his kids and all his dogs
he helps homeless dogs find new homes
and the dogs have three cute kids to
play with
as the kids get older Carlos expands he
offers dog training dogs to Dean and
more he starts a program to give dogs to
troubled kids from the aisle jane is
supportive but she makes him shower as
soon as he's done for the day she
doesn't want him to get that damp dog
smell all over the furniture they are
totally a couple in love for the rest of
their lives
and Carlos has made a huge difference in
the world he's helped other BK
and lots of dogs these two definitely
live happily ever after what do you
think Jane and Carlos named their
children let us know in the comments
thanks for watching if you want to be
chillin like a villain hit that
subscribe button for videos about d3 and
more
[Music]